どこだっけな～
夜中に友達とドンキ（ホーテ）とか行くんですけど
そのときたまたま見つけたんですよ
ああ、あった、これだ！
今回見つけたのはこちらです
何が入っているかわからない！
良いものが出るかもしれないし、出ないかもし、れない…
今回はこちら！
想定外ガチャでございます。
想定外ガチャ！
これは期待値高いですよ！
今まで回してきたのは
「謎のガチャ」と「ゲスなおもちゃガチャ」っていう
ちょっともうね、期待……………が無い。
もう期待する事すらも許されないような名前の
ガチャなんですよ。
今回は想定外ガチャでも「良いのが出るかもしれない」って書いてあるから良いのが出るかもしれない！
すげぇ当たり前なことをあたかも格好よく言ってみました。
はじめしゃちょーです。
ドンキに売っていた想定外ガチャを全部買ってきました。
今回はすごい多いよ！
そして中身はまだ見てない。
え～待ってわかんないわかんないわかんないわかんない
わかんないわかんないわかんないわかんないわかんない
こちらにあるのが想定外ガチャの中身です
あ～見ないようにしたい
19個！19個ありました。
何が出るかわからないガチャガチャシリーズ
今回は！さすがにヤバいの出るっしょ。
さすがにそろそろね、なんかこう、
3DS引換券みたいな奴が出ても
いいのではないかと思います。
では見ていきまっしょう！
では見ていきましょう、一個目です。
もう中身見えてるじゃん！
完全にこれは…
完全に妖怪メダルですね。
一個目はこちら、
妖怪メダル「デビラカダブラ」
つぎ！
（２個目）頼むぞ~
１００円以上の価値があればそれなりに良い気がしちゃう
ハアッ！
あっ、うたの、うたの、うたのプリンス、
うたのプリンスだ、コレ
「うたの☆プリンスさまっ♪」だコレ
違う「ドリフェス！」だ！
全然わかんない…
缶バッチだなこれは
ハイッ！
俺！？
あ、これもひょっとしたら黒石勇人くんのファンだと喜ぶ奴
なのかもしれないが
僕は黒石勇人くんのファンではございませんっ！
つぎいいぃぃぃ！
（３個目）はいコレ！
あぁ～ギリギリまで中身は見たくないところではある
ハァッ！
妖怪メダルや…
なんなの！？妖怪メダル余ってんの！？
つぎ
（４個目）これは期待だな、大きいぞ
ハイッ！ヤァッ！
ンン！？！？
何だねこれは
フフッちょっと、ホント待って、な、誰得なん誰得？（笑）
誰得？なにこれ！
え～待ってこれなになになになに！
これなに！？
「伝説の刀」
刀のあの部分（鍔（つば））ですね
奇跡的に刀持ってるわ。
刀のこの部分です、この部分のガチャです
マジ誰得だよホントにもおおおお！
誰の？これ誰得なの？
豊臣秀吉だ。
豊臣秀吉の奴だ。
せめて…あなたが良かった…
ワアアアァァァァ！
今んとこなにもピンと来てない。
そろそろなにかしらちょっと僕がちょっとこう、
オウオウオウってなるような奴が出てほしいんですけど
ｱｶﾞｧｲ！
（５個目）はい！アッ
（ドリフェスの）片桐いつき君…
(６個目)たまにすげぇ開かないやつがあんだけど
開いた！
ハアアアアアアァァァ
妖怪メダルゥ！
もぉ～ちょっと待って妖怪メダル率が高いぞ今回
なんかすっげぇ、なに、妖怪メダルがすごい出るぞこれ
そういうやつ？
（７個目）次はじゃあこれいきます！
開いた！はい！
お？お？お？これ、新しいぞ
「Gのレコンギスタ」、ガンダムですねぇ
ガンダムの人が入っている
うわうわ待って待って待って待って待って、
待て待て待て、
これ絶対主人公的キャラではないでしょう
コイツと隣にいるってことは、
もうそれなりのそれでしょう。多分。
つぎィ！
（８個目）はい！
あっあっあっあーーっ！
あっあっえっえっ
ええんちゃうん？今回
今回は良い気がするぞ、はいっ！
ん？
お～～～っほほぅおうおうおうおう
ん、んん～
完全にふざけてるでしょ…
えぇ！待って！待って待って、
待って！やばい待って、やばいやばいやばい
このガタガタの説明書みたいなやつ
４００円もすんの？！？！？
えっチョーお得じゃん！
でも売れ残ってたってことか…
いや～ちょっとピックアップ見てってください
こういろいろゴルゴがいるわけなんですけども、
裸のゴルゴがいないんですよ！
つまり！
シークレット！（ヒミツ）
このシークレットが多分こいつだったってことです
え、これすごくない！？
あんただって４００円もするんでしょ？
というわけでゴルゴのガチャのシークレットが出ました
これはかなりいいんじゃないですか。
当たり！
（９個目）ハイ！
ん？なにこれ？固い！
なんだこれは？リラックマ！
これかなぁ？ケースの（大）ですね
ケースの（大）じゃん！うわぁかわいい！
つぎ
今んとこ多分ゴルゴぐらいしかなんかこう、
グッと来たのがない…
（１０個目）ハイ！
「ドリフェス！」の及川慎くんです
３人目です、コンプリートが近いですね（棒）
つぎ！
（１１個目）フォゥ！えっ？あっあっあっ、
デュララララララ！
デュララララだ
わっこれ、俺見てたんだよアニメ！
なんか、見てたアニメのが出ると嬉しいすね
かわいいなぁ…
デュララララのあのあれです、
暴力的で怖い人（平和島静雄）ですね…
（因みに「デュラララ!!」です）
（１２個目）ハイッ！
ガンダム「Gのレコンギスタ」さぁ中身は果たして…
はい
あっでも、なんか主人公かな？
あれこれ主人公じゃね？
あっ主人公だ
主人公がでた、やった（ry
どんどんいきましょう
（１３個目）ハイッ！
おっ、わっ、「進撃の巨人」じゃん！
ジャン（キルシュタイン）が当たりました！
でもね他のキャラを見るとね～
もっと欲しいのが沢山いますね～
ミカサが欲しかったとこです。
つぎ！
（１４個目）ハイッ！
あっ「Gのレコンギスタ」の人
ほいっ
んんっ？悪くないな…
んん～…こっち派
残り少ない中でいかに当たりを引きつけれるかが
今回のポイントですな
（１５個目）ハイッ！
おっおっおっおっおっおっやった！やった！
はい！モクローです！
えっめっちゃかわいい！
いやモクローは完全に当たりでしょ！
えやったやったやった！
ラインナップを見てもまぁこの御三家が当たり
と言っても過言ではないなぁ
ロトムもアリだったが
いや感ｄ…うぇ、うおぉ、、嬉し～～～～い
っていうほど嬉しくはないんですけどぉ…
まぁけどこのラインナップの中で見ると、
多分滅茶苦茶当たりの方ではないでしょうか！
モクローは一番うれしいですありがとうございます！
つぎぃ！
１００円でポケモンのキーホルダー当たるの
かなりでかいね！
それもモクローとかいう人気ポジションの…
（１６個目）ハイッ！
つぎ！
（１７個目）ハイッ！
わぁた！
絶対妖怪メダルだ
あっでも！
ジバニャンです
これはいいのかな、わかんないな
ラスト２つとなりました
こっちから見ていきましょう
（１８個目）小さい方から
さぁこい！
これはなんだ…
あっ！デュラララララの人だ！
はい！首なしライダーの人ですね
（セルティ・ストゥルルソン）
普通にこれアニメ見てると嬉しい筈ですよ
いやぁ…マジャァ！？
さぁ、いよいよラスト１つとなってしまいました。
こん中にもうすべてを託す！
いやけど今回は割と当たりが多かった気がするんですよ！
そんなね、なんか今回は嫌な気持ちはしてないです。
（１９個目）じゃあラスト１個いきます！
やああぁ！！
痛アアアァ！
中身はこちらです！
（マジで危険なのでマネしないでください。）
はいっ！
このシルエットは…
こ、このシルエットはまさか！
あっ
はい、というわけでいかがだったでしょうか予想外ガチャ！
あの、多分割と悪くはなかった気がします！
はずれなのは、はずれだよ？
でもひょっとしたらこの、ドリフェスも妖怪ウォッチも
好きな人からしたら凄いうれしいのかもしれない
それ以外はそんなに悪くもなかっ....
んーーーーー
でもポケモンのモクローが入ってたのが
凄いでかかったと思います！
あ、あとシークレットの裸のあなたもね
ただ、やっていつも思うんですけど...
やめておけばよかった
♪（ＥＤテーマソング）